there are an endless amount of home  remedies that claim to reduce the  appearance of those pesky wrinkles one  of the stars go two's sleeping on your  back but does it really work well  sleeping on your back would help you be  less puffy and not get sleep lines on  your face but it is very difficult for  so many people to do that I've also  heard about people just drinking jugs  and jugs of water you don't look like a  celebrity cuz you drink a lot of water  so is there an easier way we teamed up  with rock skincare and their spokeswoman  dr. Wan Chai to bring you an accessible  anti-aging routine well I love rock  retinol correction night cream it's  clinically proven to make your skin look  up to 10 years younger and it reduces  the appearance of deep wrinkles by up to  50% where can we get it you can get it  at Walmart for under $20 which is a  steal  [Music]